[Music]
in the previous video we deployed our
htx connector and now we're going to
move on to the next step to configure
the hcx service mesh
hi my name is raj dhitnani with google
cloud and in this video we're going to
pick up where we left off where we set
up the hdx connector on-prem to pair
with the hdx manager on the cloud side
and now we're going to go to the
interconnect view and set up our network
profile compute profile and service mesh
the network profile tells hcx which
networks to land its fleet appliances
which effectively perform all the
migration functions
including the motion
the network extension the wan
optimization etc
let's go ahead and create this network
profile on a distributed port group and
since this is a lab environment we're
going to put all the traffic types on
one network group but in your
production-like environment make sure to
verify the configuration requirements
with the h6 user guide
and also make sure that your mtu set to
whatever your connection to google cloud
is whether that's through the partner
interconnect or your vpc having the
minimum being met either at 1440
or 1500
once again we're going to select the
traffic types here management hdx uplink
vc replication vmotion all on a single
port group but keep in mind this is a
simplified environment and you'll want
to configure the environment per your
environment variables and network
workgroup configurations
next
we're going to go check out the cloud
site and you can see here on the cloud
side that we already have a network
profile for different traffic types
pay special attention to the uplink
network profile mtu in order to make
sure that you don't have fragmentation
for the migration traffic
now that we're done with the network
profile let's head back on prem and
create a compute profile which is
another prerequisite before we can start
migrations
and the compute profile describes what
the underlying cluster or infrastructure
looks like for hcx to deploy its fleet
appliances
and also selects what the cluster is and
how it's configured for the vms that we
want to migrate from into
so let's go ahead and hit continue here
we're going to select the majority of
the options for the services we want to
activate
select the cluster that we want to
leverage for the workloads and then
select which cluster or resource we want
to use
for the htx fleet appliances
to leverage whether that's the storage
putting in a specific folder
etc and now we're going to select the
network profiles so the network profiles
again tells the hdx fleet appliances how
to talk to your management network how
to talk to vmotion and how to talk to
google cloud
in our case in a simplified environment
we're all going to have the
same network profile
but in a production-like environment
you're likely going to have multiple
network profiles for the different
traffic types
next we're going to select which
distributed switch that we want to
leverage for actions such as network
extensions or stretching the l2 network
if you want to be able to be motioned
with zero downtime
and then it's going to generate a list
of
firewall rules that you can pass on to
your firewall team so that they can open
up the necessary connections
now that we have the compute profile
finished and again this is already
created for you on the gcp site
automatically
we're going to combine the compute
profile on-prem with the compute profile
on the cloud side by creating a service
mesh
so we're going to select the on prime
compute profile the gcve compute profile
and go to this next step
again here you'll see the different
options enabled
if you're missing an option make sure to
check both sides of your computer
profile that make sure that's
selected
and then on this screen this is an
optional screen where you can select to
override
something outside
of your compute profile for things like
which network to use for the uplink or
migration traffic
we're also going to select how many
network extension appliances we're going
to deploy as well as
other advanced options around plan
optimization and when compression
finally i'm going to hit continue give
the service mission name
and once that's complete it'll
automatically deploy all the necessary
hcx fleet appliances
on both sides of the environment so you
only have to do this once starting with
the on-prem and it'll actually
orchestrate the deployment of the
necessary appliances
both in the on-prem environment
and in the gcbe environment
you'll also notice that it may try to
add a standalone host to your
environment which is
the mobility agent this is how vmotion
gets connected for isolated networks
once your service mesh is created make
sure to run a diagnostic check
and if everything's good in terms of
firewall rules and connections you'll
see that it'll come up with all probes
were successful
this now shows us that we have a healthy
service mesh and we're ready to migrate
our workloads and virtual machines
as mentioned before if you go to the gcb
side you'll see that the service mesh is
already created there as well
congratulations we have everything in
place now to start moving our virtual
machines to the cloud check out the next
video for the actual virtual machine
migrating over an l2 extended network
with vmotion with zero downtime to learn
more about google cloud vmware engine
visit our site at cloud.google.com
vmware dash engine
[Music]
you